GILBERT STRANG: OK.
So speaking today about
separable equations.
These are, in principle,
the easiest to solve.
They include nonlinear
equations but they
have a special feature
that makes them easy,
makes them approachable.
And that special feature
is that the right hand
side of the equation
separates into some function
of t divided by or multiplied
by some function of y.
The t and the y have separated
on the right hand side.
And for example, dy/dt equal y
plus t would not be separable.
They'd be very simple
but not separable.
Separable means that we can
keep those two separately and do
an integral of f and an integral
of g and we're in business.
OK.
Examples.
Suppose that f of y is 1.
Then we have this simplest
differential equation of all,
dy/dt is some function of t.
That's what calculus is for.
y is the integral of g.
Suppose there was no t.
Just a 1 over f of y,
with g of t equal one.
Then I bring the f of y up.
I integrate the [? f ?] dy.
And moving the dt there,
I'm just integrating dt.
So the right hand
side would just be t.
And the left hand side is
an integral we have to do.
That's the minimum
amount of work
to solve a
differential equation.
But the point is, with y
and t separate, we just
have integration to do.
And here is the case when there
is both a g of t and an f of y.
Then let me just emphasize
what's happening here.
The f of y I am
moving up with a dy.
The dt I'm moving
up with a g of t dt.
So I g of t dt equals f of y
dy and I integrate both sides.
The left side is an integral
of y with respect to y.
The right hand side is
an integral with respect
to t or a dummy variable s.
The integral going from 0 to t.
This integral going
from y of 0 to y of t.
Those are the two
integrations to be done.
And you will get examples
of seperable equations.
And what you have to
do is two integrals.
And then there's this one
little catch at the end.
This is some function
of y when I integrate.
But I usually like
to have the solution
to a differential equation
just y equal something.
And you'll see in the examples.
I have to solve it
for y because this
isn't going to give me just y.
It's going to give me some
expression involving y.
So let me do examples.
Let me do examples.
You see why it's correct.
OK.
So here are examples.
So let me take, what about the
equation dy/dt equals t over y.
Clearly separable.
The function's f.
g of t is just t.
f of y is just y.
I combine those to
y dy equalling t dt.
You see I've picked a pretty
straightforward example.
Now I'm integrating both
sides from y of 0 to y of t
on the left.
And from 0 to t on the right.
And of course that
is 1/2 t squared.
And the left hand
side is 1/2 y squared
between these two limits.
So I'm getting the integral
of that is 1/2 y squared.
So up top I have 1/2
y of t squared minus,
at the bottom end,
1/2 y of 0 squared
equalling the right
hand side 1/2 t squared.
So you see, we got a function
of y equal to a function of t.
And the equation
is solved, really.
That differential
equation is solved.
But I haven't found it in the
form y of t equal something.
But I can do that.
I just move this
to the other side.
So that will go to the
other side with a plus.
And then I'll cancel the 1/2.
And then I'll take
the square root.
So the solution y of
t is the square root
of y of 0 squared
plus t squared.
That's the solution to
the differential equation.
Maybe I make a small
comment on this equation.
Because it's essential to begin
to look for dangerous points.
Singular points where
things are not quite right.
Here the dangerous point
is clearly y equal zero.
If I start at y of 0 equals
zero then I'm not sure what.
What's the solution to that
equation if I start at y of 0
equals 0?
I'm starting with a 0 over 0.
What a way to begin your life,
starting with a 0 over 0.
This, well, actually
the solution
would still be correct.
If y of 0 is 0, I would get
the square root of t squared.
I would get t.
So y of 0 equals 0 allows
the solution y equals t.
And that is a solution.
That if y is equal
to t then dy/dt is 1.
And on the right hand side
t over y is t over t is 1.
So the equation is solved.
But my point was,
there's got to be
something going a little
strange when y of 0 is 0.
And what happens strangely
is there are other solutions.
I like, I think, y
equal negative t.
And more, probably.
But if y is equal to negative t,
then its derivative is minus 1.
And on the right hand side, I
have t over negative t minus 1
again.
So the equation is solved.
That's a perfectly
good solution.
That's a second solution.
It's an equation with
more than one solution.
And we'll have to
think, when can we
guarantee there is just
one solution, which
is of course what we want.
OK.
I'd better do another
example going beyond this.
And maybe the logistic
equation is a good one.
So that's separable.
And it's going to
be a little harder.
So let me do that one.
dy/dt is y minus y
squared, let's say.
The logistic equation.
Linear term minus
a quadratic term.
That's separable because
the g of t part is 1.
And what's the f of y?
Remember f of y-- I want
to put that on the y side.
But it's going to show
up in the denominator.
So I have dy over y minus
y squared equaling dt.
And I have to integrate both
sides to get the solution y.
Now, integrating the right hand
side is of course a picnic.
I get t.
But integrating
the left hand side,
I have to either know how,
or look up, or figure out
the integral of 1 over
y minus y squared.
So let me just make a little
comment about integrating,
because examples often
have this problem.
Integrating when
there is a polynomial
a quadratic in the denominator.
There are different
ways to do it.
And the time that we'll really
see this type of problem
is when we discuss
Laplace transforms.
So I'm going to save the details
of the method until then.
But let me give the
name of the method.
The name is partial
fractions, which
is a method of integration.
Partial fractions.
And I'll just say
here what it means.
It means that I want to write
this 1 over y minus y squared
in a nicer way.
What over y minus y squared can
be split up into two fractions?
Those are the partial fractions.
One fraction is-- so
I'm going to factor
that y minus y squared
factors into y and 1 minus y.
The partial fractions will
be some number over the y
and some other number
over the 1 minus y.
This is just algebra now.
Partial fractions
is just algebra.
It's not calculus.
So I factored the y minus y
squared into these two terms.
You see that if I come
to a common denominator,
if I put these two
fractions together,
then the denominator
is going to be that.
And the numerator, if I choose
a and b correctly, will be 1.
So, integrating this, I can
separately integrate a over y
dy and b dy over 1 minus y.
And those are easy.
So partial fractions,
after you go
to the effort of
finding the fractions,
then you have separate
integrations that you can do.
That integral is just
a times the log of y.
And this is maybe
b times-- maybe
it's minus b times
the log of 1 minus y.
So we've integrated.
Just remember though.
That with this
particular equation,
the logistic equation, we didn't
have to use partial fractions.
We could have done-- we've
just seen how, thinking
of it as a separable equation.
But that logistic equation
had the very neat approach.
Much quicker, much nicer.
We just introduced
z equal 1 over y.
We looked at the unknown
1 over y, called it z,
found the equation for
z, and it was linear.
And we can write
down its solution.
So when we can do that it wins.
But if we don't
see how to do that,
partial fractions is
the systematic way.
One fraction, another fraction.
Integrate those fractions.
Put the answer together.
And then, and then,
at the end, this
is some integral
depending on y equal to t.
And to finish the
problem perfectly,
I would have to solve
for y as a function of t.
And that was what came out
so beautifully by letting 1
over y bz.
We got an easy formula for z and
then we had the formula for y.
This we would integrate
easily enough.
But then we have to solve
to find that formula for y.
OK.
That's a more serious example.
This example was
a very simple one.
You can do other examples
of separable equations.
y and t integrated separately.
Good.
Thank you.